[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight here's a fact that'll
make you blink we are now approaching
the 19th
anniversary of the arrival of american
troops in
afghanistan they're still there despite
repeated promises from politicians on
both sides
they're not going anywhere for the
meantime and americans are still dying
there
that's true in iraq too we've had troops
in iraq for 17 years why are they there
no one knows why they're there at least
no one will say so out loud with any
clarity
many thousands of american servicemen
are deployed in many dozens of countries
around the world
and have been for generations now in
some cases there may very well be a good
reason they're there in many other cases
though we just don't talk about it
you're not allowed to in washington
mindless interventionism
is very much a bipartisan project both
parties support it
just this summer republicans and
democrats reached a rare moment of unity
they joined together to demand that we
keep thousands of american troops
in germany where they've been for 75
years
why should they stay another 75 or
presumably to keep the soviet union from
evading
hamburg maybe there's another reason no
one mentioned what that reason might be
the more troops we send overseas the
better that is one thing virtually
everyone in washington agrees on except
donald trump
trump whatever you think of him does not
agree he does not believe that and he
said so for the last
five years trump has been talking
relentlessly about bringing the troops
home from countries around the world
and maybe more than any other single
reason
talk like that makes official washington
hate donald trump
last night the white house announced
that we're finally bringing home many
american soldiers from iraq and
afghanistan
and you would think there would be
widespread celebration that means
families united
americans out of harm's way but very few
in washington
are celebrating the press corps
including some people who should know
better
are still busy telling you how much
donald trump hates the troops
and wants them to die the guy who's
bringing them home
add that to the irony file which is
bulging
so what exactly is going on here well
one clue comes from the deputy assistant
secretary of defense a woman called
laura cooper
cooper testified before congress during
the impeachment proceedings last year
and during those proceedings she said
that pentagon officials
began receiving quote phone calls from
industry
in other words calls from private
companies that produce and supply
weapons and military hardware to our
military
after the white house put a hold on
high-priced military aid to ukraine
so weapons manufacturers wanted more
weapons flowing into ukraine because
they wanted to make money from the sale
of those weapons
it's not complicated and they knew they
could pressure the pentagon to override
a decision by the democratically elected
president of the united states
that's what they did this happens a lot
and everyone in washington knows it on
labor day the president finally
said this out loud he called out the
defense industry for the first time in
decades
watch this biden shipped away our jobs
threw open our borders and sent
our youth to fight in these crazy
endless wars and it's one of the reasons
the military i'm not saying the military
is in love with me the soldiers are
the top people in the pentagon probably
aren't because they want to
do nothing but fight wars so that all of
those wonderful companies that make the
bombs and make the planes and make
everything else stay happy
so there's a lot of truth in that and
the president of the united states
would know and precisely because a lot
of what trump said
is true donald trump was not allowed to
say it out loud
democrats and the media were enraged
that he said that
nearly half of senior defense department
officials are linked with military
contractors
no one ever says that out loud and if
you do what do you hate the troops
what is going on here you might think
it's purely partisan
that this dishonesty is a way to get rid
of trump but install joe biden and his
handlers and there's no doubt that
that's
part of what's going on but there's
something bigger
democrats and some republicans by the
way are priming the public
for revival of interventionism if joe
biden and kamala harris are elected
if they make it to the white house biden
and harris are planning a new war
this one in the far away and
strategically irrelevant nation of syria
they're not even trying to hide that and
they haven't been for a long time
back in 2018 we were told we need to
intervene in syria immediately
because bashar al-assad the leader of
that country had used chemical weapons
against his own people every channel
told you that
this show noted correctly that there
wasn't actually any evidence that had
happened
despite what they were telling you there
was a lot of lying going on
and that's never been proven by the way
despite what they say
but the left didn't even ask questions
they swallowed the whole thing
whole the first day watch the hysterics
about it on msnbc
if vladimir putin if if
vladimir putin masterminded the last
week in syria
he has gotten everything he could have
asked for
do a small chemical attack nothing
nothing like the big ones you've done in
the past
and then donald trump can fire some
missiles at syria
that'll do no real damage and then the
american news media will change the
subject
from russian influence in the trump
campaign and the trump transition
in the trump white house it's perfect
oh it's perfect this is lunacy
who cares how much of syria vladimir
putin controls good luck with it
rational people who cared about the
united states realized
that syria was a classic quagmire and
there was no
obvious advantage for us the us in
committing
large numbers of troops there we argued
at the time
that a foreign war staged on behalf of
the so-called syrian rebels many of them
in fact islamic extremists who hate our
country
was unwise it was obviously unwise
in the end the president settled on
firing some rockets into syria it was a
very short
story but this enraged official
washington bureaucratic tapeworms like
john bolton were furious
bolton declared that the absence of a
total all-out war with massive american
troop commitment was a quote
personal crisis later the president said
we were pulling entirely out of syria he
memorably called syria a land of
sand and death the syrian civil war is
still ongoing by the way and for war
porn purveyors like john bolton
and other liberals it's still an
opportunity at a fundraiser this summer
joe biden declared that the president's
approach to syria is not enough
crippling unprecedented sanctions are
not enough biden said we need to
escalate
in syria now you've seen this logic
before we saw it in iraq
that was bipartisan joe biden supported
the iraq war he doesn't want to talk
about it now
when asked about it by a veteran he used
the tragic death of his son from cancer
as a shield from the question watch i'm
an air force
i'm not going after yourself
so this moment is bewildering to people
who haven't followed the shifts in
american politics over the last 30 years
liberals used to say they were against
war give peace a chance remember that
now joe biden's unquestioning support
for wars
wars that don't help this country at all
is one of his chief qualifications as a
democratic nominee
in may biden's foreign policy adviser
tony blinken confirmed that a joe biden
administration would be eager to get the
united states into a war in syria
lincoln described american troops in
syria that would be
americans risking their lives as a form
of quote
leverage right lincoln vowed that joe
biden will return to syria
in force if he wins in november
and to the extent the united states had
any remaining leverage in syria to try
to effectuate
some more positive outcome unfortunately
the trump administration has more or
less torn that up too
pulling out entirely
in in syria has taken away significant
leverage
leverage for what how does this help us
nobody ever answers the simplest of all
questions the most profound the only
question that matters
lincoln added that is quote virtually
impossible for him to imagine a biden
administration
normalizing relations with assad's
government again he didn't even address
how sanctioning syria helps the united
states because that's not the point it
is never the point
last night john kerry made the case in
msnbc that no one loves the troops more
than john kerry does of course
the obama administration may have lied
about its plans to withdraw from
afghanistan it didn't
of course the obama administration
turned the nation of libya into a
hellscape of civil war and slavery
but trust me says john kerry i love the
troops watch
we have a president who is not
protecting our troops
not protecting the interests of the
united states of america these young men
and women are
extraordinary in today's generation they
serve willingly they're volunteers
and they deserve certainly the respect
of the commander-in-chief if not every
single american
oh okay so john kerry respects our
troops so much
but he would like to send them to
countries you can't find on a map put
them in places where they may
die for purposes that have nothing to do
with our national security
or the advancement of american interests
only to support
crumbling post-war international
institutions that everyone knows is a
joke and are going away
that's john kerry he respects our troops
it was just last month that kerry who
again
unlike trump cares about the truth and
the troops
took the stage of the democratic
national convention and long for the
days when hundreds of thousands of our
soldiers
died in world war ii watch the only
thing
exceptional about the incoherent trump
foreign policy
is that it has made our nation more
isolated than ever before
on june 6 1944 young americans gave
their lives on the beaches of normandy
to liberate the world from tyranny out
of the ashes of that war
we made peace and rebuilt the world that
was
and remains exceptional it is the
opposite of
everything donald trump stands for
oh that was the golden books version of
world war ii
cliche piled upon cliche upon cliche
mindless it's propaganda democratic
voters are starting to believe it
one poll shows that among people who
voted for hillary clinton in 2016
just 26 percent now support withdrawing
troops from syria
pollsters didn't ask why they should
stay but almost no democrats are for
pulling them out
by contrast nearly 60 percent oppose
pulling out trump voters overwhelmingly
support withdrawing from syria
they must hate the troops wanting them
home instead of suffering for years in
some
remote country that has no connection to
the united states what is going on here
exactly